538 ANY LONGER BECAUSE IT IS
ESSENTIALLY REPUBLICAN
PROPAGANDA.
>> LAURA: OH, SIMON, COME
ON. JOINING US IS TOM BEVIN.
YOUR REACTION ON THIS
ASSAULT ON THE CLEAR POLITIC
SITES AND AVERAGES, IT IS
ALL REPUBLICAN PROPAGANDA.
YOUR REACTION TONIGHT?
>> A COUPLE OF POINTS TO
MAKE. NUMBER ONE, IT IS THE
REPUBLICAN FIRMS LIKE OTHERS
WHO BEEN MORE ACCURATE OVER
THE LAST THREE CYCLES THAN
MOST POLLING FIRMS. IT IS
BEEN LIKE OTHER FIRMS LIKE
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND
SIENNA THAT HAVE BIG MISSES
AND ACCURATE. POINT NUMBER
TWO IS NOT TRUE THAT THESE
ARE ALL REPUBLICAN POLLS.
YOU MENTIONED NEW HAMPSHIRE,
WE HAD A MORNING CALL POLL
IN PENNSYLVANIA SHOWED THAT
RACE IS TIED. WE HAVE 15
POLLS IN OUR GENERIC
CONGRESSIONAL BALLOT, THE
AVERAGE IS ABOUT 2.8 FOR
REPUBLICANS. EVEN THE
DEMOCRATIC FIRMS LIKE
DEMOCRACY CORE HAD
REPUBLICANS UP TWO POINTS.
DATA FOR PROGRESS HAD
REPUBLICANS UP FOUR POINTS.
IT IS NOT TRUE THIS IS SOME
SORT OF GRAND CONSPIRACY
TRYING TO MANIPULATE THE
HOURS. THEY DON'T LIKE WHAT
THEY WERE SEEING.
>> LAURA: THEY WERE NOT
CLAIMING ANY PROBLEMS EIGHT
WEEKS AGO WHEN DEMOCRATS
LOOKED PRETTY GOOD IN THESE
STATES. THERE IS NO
CONSPIRACY THEN BUT THERE IS
A CONSPIRACY ON
NOVEMBER 1ST. DEMOCRATS ONLY
HAD THEMSELVES TO BLAME
BECAUSE NEW REPORTING
REVEALING THAT, THEY SPENT
NEARLY $320 MILLION ON ADS
FOCUSED ON ABORTION, MORE
THAN TEN TIMES AS MUCH AS
THE 31 MILLION THEY SPENT ON
SPOTS ABOUT INFLATION.
THAT'S ACCORDING TO ADD
IMPACT THAT TRACKS THE
MEDIA. THAT'S THEIR
DECISION-MAKING THAT CAME
INTO PLAY, CORRECT? THAT WAS
A BAD CALL IT TURNS OUT.
>> THAT HAS BEEN THE
STRATEGY. THE DATA ON THIS
HAS BEEN REALLY CLEAR FOR
MONTHS AND MONTHS. I MEAN IT
WAS CLEAR BEFORE THE DOBBS
DECISION LEAKED. THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUES ON THE
MINDS OF MAJORITY VOTERS AND
SUPER MAJORITY OF
REPUBLICANS BUT ALSO
MAJORITY OF INDEPENDENT
VOTERS OF ECONOMY AND GAS
PRICES AND JOBS AND ETCETERA
AND ABORTION WAS WELL DOWN
THE LIST. DEMOCRATS THOUGHT
THAT ISSUE WAS GOWNING TO BE
A GAME CHANGER AND IT
CERTAINLY DID HELP MOTIVATE
THEIR BASE AND ENERGY THEIR
BASE. THE PROBLEM IS NOT
WHERE THE MAJORITY OF
INDEPENDENT VOTERS ARE.
THAT'S LEFT THEM LOOKING OUT
OF TOUCH. INDEPENDENT VOTERS
ARE ASKING AND WANTING
CANDIDATES ABOUT THE ECONOMY
AND INFLATION AND DEMOCRATS
ARE FOCUSED ON THE ISS